Hey look guys my name is Jonah and
welcome back to my sequel Plus series
today we're going to be talking about in
ohms instead what was so enormous short
for enumeration and basically all it is
is a set of values if you want a more
practical definition than all Menem is
is a way to give a name to a value so
instead of having a bunch of integers
called ABC we can have an enum which has
the values ABC which correspond to
integers it also helped us define a set
of values so that instead of just having
an integer as a type which of course you
could assign any integer to you limit
which values can be assigned to what
so without complicating things that's
really all that it is it's just a way to
name values it's very useful for when
you want to use integers to represent
certain states or certain values however
you want to give them a name so that
your code is more readable at the end of
the day an enum is just an integer
however in your code it looks a little
bit different and it helps to keep your
credit bit cleaner let's dive in and
take a look so suppose that I have three
values that I wanted to take care of
I had a which I might set to zero B
which I might have set to 1 and C which
I might set to so I have 3 values to
take care of and then somewhere in mean
I might use my value and I might set it
equal to one of these 3 later on my code
I might have some code to check what the
current value is and then perform some
sort of action this is fine however it
carries a few issues
first of all these ABCs are not grouped
at all somewhere later in your code you
might have a D or you might want to
declare a again and suddenly this is a
bit of an issue but essentially the
biggest problem here is that these
aren't groups at all furthermore they
are just integers meaning I can assign
something like 5 here and suddenly this
doesn't make any sense anymore we want
to be able to essentially define a type
which can only be one of these three and
it's also grouped in some kind of
fashion which is exactly what items can
be useful so instead of this I can have
my enum which are for example and then I
can list off which values I want to have
here such as a B or C instead of having
an integer as my type I can now use the
enum name as an actual type so I can
write example value
I'm going to change my integers to be
lowercase here just so that I can use my
enum values properly and you can see
that I can assign my value just like
this if I try and assign something else
I'll get an error because it has to be
one of these three now these are just
integers at the end of the day keep that
in mind I can still do a check if I if I
reverted back to B I can still do a
check such as value equals equals 1
because the does carry the value 1 if
you hover your mouse over this it will
even tell you the B is 1 you can
actually specify the value of n should
be variable 2 well if you don't by
default the first one will be 0 and then
it will increment one by one successful
value you just set it equal to something
so I could have this is 0 this is 256
whatever you really want if you start
from a number that is not 0 such as 5
and you don't actually specify the rest
of these values you can see that this
will be 6 and this will be 7 because it
will basically just starts on 5 and then
keep going up one other thing that you
can also do here is specify which type
of integer you want the Xenon to be and
you can do so by writing a colon and
then the data types are for example an
unsigned char enum is by default are
32-bit integers however you can see in
this case there's no need for us to use
the 32-bit value we could get away with
using an 8-bit integer such as a non
fine char and we'd be just fine and
suddenly it's taking way less memory you
won't be able to assign this to
something like a float of course because
the flow instance and integer and it has
to be an integer so let's leave this as
a chart for our example so there we go
that's basically what I mean arm is just
a way to give a name to certain values
so that you don't have to keep dealing
with integers and be all over the place
let's take a look at a real world
example of where you might use any
number looking at our log clock that we
started writing in the how to write a
super clock last video if we jump over
here to our low class you can see what
we actually ended up doing was using
three different log levels and they were
just integers here 0 1 2 hopefully you
can see it is pretty much a perfect
candidate for an enum because we have
three values which we just use as
integers to represent a certain state in
this case which log level our log will
actually display so right over here
inside this low class I'm going to
create a level in um I'm
to create error warning and info as
possible value
so we're basically mirroring this as a
matter of style I actually like to
explicitly write equals zero however
that's definitely not required because
it will start at zero by default again
just something I like doing to help the
readability of the code I'll get rid of
these now instead of having an int as my
log level which I could still have of
course I could still find this to infer
and since any number is just an end this
would still work however in this case I
would be able to set any value to log
level any integer value to log level and
I want to restrict it to just being
there 3 so I will actually surface to be
level nodes of this restriction that
I've created of it must be do these
three purely syntactical service kind of
compiler and for things you can get
around it really easily it's not
something that can't physically be set
of course in this case our enum is just
a 4 byte integer it's just 4 bytes of
memory you can put anything you want
into that memory however by setting the
type to level you're restricting the
code so to speak to actually only allow
levels I'll change my set level to take
a new level now when I do these checks
they will still work just fine I just
need to change log level error to just
be error because M log level is this
enum type which is an integer
I can still do comparisons between them
which is very very useful to things like
this I'll change this to say warning and
I'll change this to say info the other
thing the changes here is the log set
level instead of being logged on log
level error which used to be that
integer it now simply becomes the log
error because we have an anon value
called error inside our log namespace
notice that this enum level is not a
name safe in itself there is something
called an enum class which we will talk
about in another video however just a
regular email this level isn't really
named safe so you can't use it as one
which means it is error warning and info
simply use it inside this log class and
you can see I can set it to something
like warning as well and everything fine
now you might have noticed error doesn't
actually work and it gives us an error
the reason this is happening is because
we actually have a function called error
as well so the same name
I sort of deliberately to show you what
happens if you have a conflicting name
now in this case unfortunately that
wouldn't work because when we try and
refer to things like Eric here it
doesn't know we're friends it's not so
we definitely can't have something
called a ratio unfortunately if you want
to have a function with the same name so
now we can just add a level prefix to
the enum which by the way is very very
common practice so that we know exactly
what we're referring to
since this name doesn't really mean much
in the scope of things so I'll tell it's
equal to level info this two-level error
sista level warning and this level info
and now what I don't need this I can get
rid of this and just type is equal to
level error if I run my code you can see
that I would get a result that I expect
well in the error is printing of course
because we've set our level to be error
so there you go and I'm just essentially
this to make our lives easier and to
make our code cleaner they are just
integers behind the scenes and you can
use them pretty much in any way like
integers there are many many uses for in
ohms which we will cover in future
videos we'll definitely talk about in
our classes as well in another video but
essentially whenever you have a set of
values which you want to represent
numerically any numbers probably the way
to go I'll see you guys next time good
bye
[Music]
[Music]